LAURENCE EAVES: The number today
I'd like to talk to you
about is 69.
And it turns out to be an
important number for this
little pocket calculator.
Well, in order to explain
this, I need to tell you
something about factorial
numbers.
I'm going to just start off by
explaining what the symbol
factorial n is, where n is an
integer, eg, 1, 2, 3, 4, any
integer like that.
Well, it's n with an exclamation
mark after it.
And it's got a special meaning
in mathematics.
It doesn't mean n,
shouted out loud.
It's just got a special
symbol in mathematics.
Now, factorial 1 is trivial.
1 factorial is just itself.
But factorial 2, well, that's
pretty uninteresting as well.
It's just 1 times 2, and
that's equal to 2.
And factorial 3 is equal to 1
times 2 times 3, which is
equal to 6.
And factorial 4 is 1 times 2
times 3 times 4, which is
equal to 24.
Now, if we go to factorial 5,
that's about as far as I can
go without having to write
things down and work out
easily in my head, but
that's equal to 120.
So these numbers increase
quite quickly.
So it's fun just to work out
factorial 20, and I can do
that by continuing
this process.
But it's much easier to get
out my pocket calculator.
So let's do 20.
So there's 20 going in, and
now I notice, to get the
factorial, there it is.
It's x with an exclamation mark
in, and that's in yellow.
So I've got to press the Shift
key, and then I press the key,
20 factorial all ready to go.
So now I put equals, and this
comes out to be 2.432902008--
and that was the
important bit--
times 10 to the 18.
So this is now really quite
a large number.
That number is much, much bigger
than the number of
stars in our galaxy and a bit
smaller than the number of
stars in the observable
universe.
Now 69, if we work out factorial
69, it turns out
that this is the largest number,
factorial number, that
I can calculate on my little
pocket calculator here.
69, and then we do Shift, and
what do I get for that?
I get 1.711224524--
and that's when my calculator
stops-- times 10 to the 98.
Now, you can see we're getting
quite close to this big number
of 10 to the 100 here.
And it turns out that that is
the largest number, I can--
factorial number I can complete
on my calculator.
If I go to the next number,
factorial 70, which, of
course, is just factorial
69 times 70.
So I'll put in, and then try
to work out the factorial.
What do I get?
BRADY HARAN: Error.
LAURENCE EAVES: So I get
error, which means the
number's become too big
for my calculator.
Now, factorial numbers are
interesting in themselves.
But for us physicists, they
really are very important in
statistics and in statistical
physics.
These things crop up in very
beautiful ways and lead to all
sorts of exotic things, like the
properties of electrons,
and even the properties of
those other sources of
particles, bosons.
But that's a bit of
another story.